the stabilizer or proportional to an element of the stabilizer and here's why first because e and C give us the
same syndrome C * e must give us the all plus one syndrome that's because for a given
stabilizer generator either c and e both commute with that generator or they both anticommute it has to be the same for
both because the syndromes are the same and if you think about that for just a moment it implies that c * e must
commute with all the stabiliz generators and finally C * e has to be
down in the stabilizer because its weight can't be larger than the sum of the weights of c and e and so its weight
is strictly less than D and this means that we successfully correct e because applying e followed by C does nothing to
the code space so that's great but there's just one problem and that is that for stabilizer
codes in general it's a computationally difficult problem to compute the lowest weight operation causing a given
syndrome and indeed that's true even for classical codes which in this context we can think about as stabilizer codes
where we only have identity matrices and polyc matrices appearing as tensor factors within the stabilizer
generators so unlike the encoding step Clifford operations don't come to our rescue this time and the only reasonable
solution is to choose specific codes for which good Corrections can be computed efficiently and there's no recipe for
this simply put devising stabilizer codes like this is part of the Artistry
of Quantum Code design and that is a good place to stop for this lesson I hope you will join me
for the next lesson in which we'll take a look at some specific Quantum Code constructions including codes that illustrate the Artistry of Quantum Code
design in a pretty spectacular way goodbye for now